[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation an awesome show we have for
you today we will be talking about the
future of meat we'll be talking about
plant-based meat cultured meat we have
an epic guest to be talking about this
with us today dr. Luis Peck thank you
for joining us on the show thank you for
having me yes and we have lots of
similar circles and like families of
like good food institute people and like
clean meet people and biotech
entrepreneurs and I'm just so happy to
be talking about this on the show more
often because this is such a crucial
part of a clean sustainable long-term
food ecosystem absolutely and it's just
really fun to geek out about there's a
lot of really fundamental science and
technology that's super cool in this
field it's like I don't want to kill a
million chickens per hour in the United
States I'm so sick of that yeah that's
so yesterday that's yes it's so
yesterday we are okay let yeah so let's
let's start by talking you because you
have you are you have a PhD and you did
that at UCSD in biological sciences
prior to that at Johns Hopkins and you
did post doc research at Boulder with
whole cell bio sensor platforms you've
been a TA you've you this is all very
exciting because to me it's it's
important to understand the person's
background then like you obviously fell
in love with biotech yeah how did that
happen yeah so I've always been a little
bit of a nerd
I'll be honest good yeah pretty
scientifically inclined but also curious
to use technology in science to make the
world a better place and so you know I
I kind of was drawn into chemical
engineering at first and and there was a
sub track within the chemical
engineering major at Johns Hopkins on
biomolecular engineering and that was
when my blunt my mind was blown for the
first time about what a cool kind of
toolkit biology has given us to build
things that never existed before or that
natural selection you know wouldn't be
incentivized to make but that could be
really useful for us and and solving
some of the challenges that we have
played a part in in you know creating in
the world to be honest
and so I I was interested in you know
using the power of biological systems
and and this beautiful principle of you
know exponential growth that these
systems exhibit and using that to do
good in the world so I was kind of
initially gravitated towards sort of
public health applications of biotech so
my graduate research was in an algae lab
actually but the projects that drew me
into that lab were could we use algae as
a production platform for a therapeutic
or for a vaccine that you could make at
massive scale at really low cost to make
that accessible to people say in
developing regions of the world algae is
very able to be grown massive quantities
for lots of purposes exactly its
ubiquitous it's got really cool kind of
biological diversity of different
pathways inside various you know
different domains of the algal world and
all of that I love how you said that
you're like we're not waiting for
evolution anymore we're gonna make all
right so we can't afford to wait for
evolution so so yeah that that kind of
drew me into global health I'd spent a
couple of summer's abroad when I was in
college you know doing water sample
testing in communities in India and so
yeah so that was kind of my exposure to
you know populations where frankly
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit from
a technology
perspective you could do relatively
straightforward things and have a
massive impact for the better on
millions of people's lives or billions
of people's lives so that that was kind
of where I was really geeking out for
several years I love that I'm just
feeling you talk about that in it and it
warms me to see how much you care yeah
and you that you said that you you
started seeing it as a as somewhere
where you could help with the technology
with biotech with hated was helping
reduce suffering with these low-hanging
fruits and that to me is a mindset that
I would love for more people to tear
about yeah I mean I definitely
appreciate people who just love science
for science and sake but for me that
could never get me going I need
something applied I need something
concrete in the world to be sort of
working towards so after my graduate
work I went and did a postdoc for a
couple of years and this is where I was
building basically a set of tools that
could someday serve as diagnostic in you
know say a remote resource limited
setting so can we use biotechnology to
create biosensors that could look for
you know whether it's a disease pathogen
or may
an environmental contaminant or
something like that and have it kind of
baked into that organism to to you know
give you a readout when it senses
something like that and what was the one
that you engineered to be a bio sensor
so the I was working just in simple lab
bacteria so you know simplest system to
engineer very straightforward what was
it detect a fancy yes
so my platform was kind of antigen
agnostic so it's more about can we build
a system that's taking a signal from
outside the cell and turn on basically a
cascade of activity within the cell that
causes the cell to for example change
color so to express so this was really
building off of a lot of work that's
been going on in the synthetic biology
world to have these kind of you know
they design them out just like an
electrical engineering circuit basically
like you've got these you know Julian
logic on/off you know input to output
and you can modulate all of that that is
genetic engineering and expressions
being a god of the expressions which is
super exciting stuff that's pretty cool
yeah so so yeah I was doing my postdoc
loved my projects loved my advisor loved
my lab everything was perfect except for
some reason I started going down this
rabbit hole of like reading about animal
agriculture and the way in which we
currently produce meat and dairy and
eggs and other animal products and all
of the kind of externalized consequences
of that environmentally you know public
health risks health risks to us as
individuals consuming those animal
welfare considerations and so all of a
sudden I was in a situation where the
thing I had become most passionate about
was not the thing I was addressing in my
day job yes and so it kind of it
actually wasn't obvious to me at first
how do I use a biotech background to
address something like
agriculture and it always struck me as
you know this is a consumer education
issue or this is a policy problem or
something like that right how do we
incentivize people to shift their
dietary behavior
it didn't seem like the kind of thing
that I could touch with my background
and so it was a bit of a light bulb
moment for me and it only came about
when I heard of the good food Institute
that yeah absolutely you can use you
know biology background a chemical
engineering backgrounds a biochemistry
background to make better food products
that compete on three attributes tastes
price convenience which are what drives
basically all consumer food buying
behavior tastes price convenience yeah
so how could you make products that
satisfy satisfy those without compromise
without asking people to to you know
deal with a subpar substitution but do
it without involving the animal how
could you do it without animal
agriculture and all of those externalize
costs I envisioned envision to you like
two and a half years ago just like like
sorting through all this craziness about
animal agriculture and suffering and the
unsustainable ecosystems and you were
like I care so much about this but I'm
not doing it in my day to day life how
do I find this and then and then good
food Institute came was that a how did
you get linked up with good food
Institute yeah so I threw a couple of
introductions it was really really
fortuitous timing like looking back I
don't know how I got this lucky me too
so GF I was formed almost three years
ago where we're about three years old as
an organization and I've been with them
for almost two and a half years so the
time at which I found the job posting
through the senior scientists role and
applied to it it had just been put up
and this was just kind of the point in
my life where I was having this you know
the through this grappling process and
so it was a perfect fit you know I read
the job description and I said wow this
someone wrote this for me yeah
like mine oh yes a wild ride because
we've grown really quickly as an
organization and you know we engage with
all these different sectors that's
really mind-blowing compared to just
being in one academic research lab after
another where you know it feels very
familiar and comfortable but but
applicability of what you're doing to
the real world drives you yeah and I'm
just I'm just so happy that you had that
it almost felt like it was the perfect
opportunity manifesting itself for you
and those moments are so they're so
strange they they make me feel they're
serial they make me feel like there's
something going on in the cosmos in this
universe that how did that line up you
know how did how did this line up yeah
all this different type of stuff so yeah
so cool so now let's do some good food
Institute unpacking let's explore so
over the last so the mission is to
promote this healthy humane sustainable
food supply across our world and how
does good food Institute do that yeah so
we it's it's kind of a funny role for a
non-profit right how do we engage with
an emerging industry and help support
that kind of innovation ecosystem so we
do it in several different ways we have
multiple different departments within
our organization that are kind of
pushing on different pieces of this
puzzle so we have our Science and
Technology department that's obviously
where I reside we do a lot of kind of
mapping out the landscape of technology
needs for developing better plant-based
products as well as for bringing some of
these cell based products cellular
agriculture products to market which we
can talk about in a second just then
like a library of you working with the
different companies in plant base in
celle Aegon yeah so if our process for
kind of defining what are these key
challenges is a mixture of reading
through the scientific literature
talking with folks in industries so
people at these startups people in other
industries so you know
in the established life science industry
or folks in the meat industry who have
meat science expertise we actually talk
to a lot of people on that side
so yeah kind of hearing from everyone
what are your bottlenecks what are your
sticking points what what challenges do
you face that if someone came up with a
solution it would allow you to go
further and faster and then we put those
into a couple different channels to
basically get that that kind of menu of
needs in front of different scientific
communities who are in a position to
address those needs so we publish white
papers we have a couple peer-reviewed
papers we write pieces for like trade
journals and industry journals and then
we also speak a lot at conferences so I
spend quite a bit of my day-to-day job
going and talking to stem cell
biologists or cell culture engineers or
again meat scientists or synthetic
biologists basically or their science
and tech yes that's yeah undersize yeah
we're in the first department the white
papers and the speaking and the
organization of this information is all
under science intent yeah and then we
also we interface with so after kind of
mapping out what are some of these
high-impact projects that we'd like to
see addressed then we go out and
actually interface with scientists who
can address those so we work with
academic researchers we work directly
with these startups and help kind of
refine their technical plan and and you
know provide connections or
opportunities that we think would
eliminate some of their hurdles or at
least alleviate them and then the other
thing we work on is getting funding for
that work so we we work on both the
private and the public side of that so
interfacing with government agencies
like NSF and NIH and really trying to
how much do they allocate
towards this every year very little
right now are we talking like ten
million dollars or less than that ah
maybe less than that very little yeah
yeah so I guess I'm making unfortunate
this is something that we've seen you
can allocate more across the field is
that some of these particularly on the
cellular agriculture side of things god
we just put a hundred billion more
dollars into our military industrial
great works yeah and yet addressing you
know these food sustainability issues
these years leaders in this across the
world yeah yeah yes making a better
balance between those two between
foreign policy as well as domestic food
supply food security yeah absolutely
like I think this is it's part and
parcel to the mission of so many of our
government agencies so part of our time
is spent basically trying to get them to
see that right and to allocate more more
resources in this direction and then we
also talked with folks like venture
capital firms and angel investors and
even corporate venture arms so folks who
are kind of sold on the market potential
of this space they see this this
fabulous growth of for example these
plant-based products but they they need
sometimes a little help digging into the
technical side of things and in doing
the scientific side of their due
diligence for these companies are you
aware of the 50 years a lot magicians
are you good and then I'm Mariana Cinco
yes well you yes yes okay okay cool I
wanted to make sure you were connected
otherwise we would because they're very
future foodies yeah yeah and I think
it's important for you you people like
that to me actually that's my community
is really excited about this so there's
a lot of advocates for more investors in
this space and frankly a lot of you know
very collaborative kind of sharing
information showing deal flow things
like that because I think a lot of
people this is not just a way of making
money it's it's part of their job that
they actually feel equally passionate
about
which is very cool this is about a
long-term sustainable future and I love
that part about this is so so where did
the funding the Govan venture funding
does that still science and tech that's
septal yeah so that's that's still
mostly science and technology but kind
of bleeds into our other okay Department
so we've got an innovation department so
they also work with investors as well as
startup companies so they really exist
to make it easier for a startup company
to innovate in this space and to succeed
so they give them support not so much on
the technical side but on you know their
business plan and their pitch deck and
introductions to people who can help
them then we have a you guys work with
some of the indie bio companies that are
in the clean means yes absolutely yeah
yep that's awesome yeah we work with
quite a few kind of tech incubators and
and biotech incubators we actually in
this latest round of Y Combinator we
were one of the few nonprofits that they
accepted into their program so we got to
you know participate in their they're
sort of trainings and programmatic work
and then we actually got to teach at
demo day for later sweet yeah yeah yeah
so that's innovation we have a corporate
engagement team that mostly is working
with kind of established food industry
yeah including meat companies but also
you know just kind of big food at large
as well as retailers so grocery stores
yeah yeah exactly
do you serve ready to hold the products
that are coming in exactly excited to
hold those products yeah so really
working on kind of opening up
distribution and you know making sure
that these plant-based products once
they they can kind of ramp up production
capacity which is actually one of their
bottlenecks right now demand is
outstripping their ability to produce
them fast enough
but making sure that these these doors
are open to these products to really
scale quickly science and tech and then
innovation and in the corporate outreach
yeah so there's three me know there's 17
actually our next kind of for a core
programmatic arm is our policy team so
they work on a few main fronts one is
kind of paving the way from a regulatory
perspective for some of these products
that are brand new to market so you know
the cell based meats and things like
that that that have not already been on
the food scene if we get through the FDA
it's still up in the air actually which
agency will be in charge of this because
USDA regulates meat FDA regulates other
food products and so there's actually
some really interesting conversations
going on between the agencies will you
tell it to just a bit about that quick
is that absolutely new to me and I bet
other people yeah so there's I mean this
is like as soon as I say something about
this it'll be outdated because they're
like literally on Monday there is a
series of meetings starting that are
hosted by FDA and USDA to kind of
explore the technology figure out you
know how does this fit within existing
frameworks you know who has the best
expertise to evaluate and and is it
different if you're talking about you
know pre market kind of safety review
versus ongoing inspection of production
facilities and things like that yeah um
so yeah it's a really fascinating
conversation that's going on so our
policy team does a lot of kind of
coordinating for the industry because
the industry is is still a bunch of
really young startup companies you know
so there's a need for kind of a central
voice there for these these types of
discussions so that's a big part of what
our policy team does they also work kind
of more on the legislative side with
some of these issues around how do you
label these products and there's a term
called standards of identity which means
you know can you call soy milk milk or
is that inviolate
and of a standard of identity so there's
a lot of again you call clean meat meat
exactly there's one of those questions
yeah yeah
so interesting to be seen but I think
again the central charge for us and as
an organization trying to help you know
promote and support this industry is
that we don't want any kind of
restrictions or handicaps that would
prevent these plant-based and cell based
alternatives from competing on a level
playing field with their kind of
conventional animal based counterparts
and then our policy team also I was just
envisioning walking into the grocery
stores and just seeing whole sections of
plant-based and cell-based yes to choose
from instead of just people are like why
would I you know why would I take pick
the slaughtered animal versions and and
did some it's even cheaper to pick the
plant and the cell based versions is
healthier and it's sustainable yeah I'm
so excited we're getting there yeah
hopefully add a decade yeah and then
policy also works with us a little bit
to help kind of get get language into
appropriations bills and things like
that to get more Rd dollars dedicated to
these areas and then finally I don't
quit after this one okay we have an
international engagement team yeah
that's basically a multiplier for all of
the work that we're doing that's
predominantly in the US but we do have a
global purview where's like the second
big GFI hub so we so we have managing
directors in Israel Brazil India China
just recently we hired so hey we're
looking to have someone in Europe and in
fairly short yeah yeah and so right now
all of those places are just one or two
people but our India managing director
is really building out his team there's
a lot of talent in the country on the
kind of biotech side of things I love
seeing those very short videos of how
India is doing things like just getting
rid of our single-use items yeah that
that's so good okay so spreading across
the world fantastic
policy innovation tech science
okay so let's unpack the more of the
nuance of the alternatives yeah yeah so
when we talk about alternative proteins
I'm thinking about it from a production
standpoint right from a facility or a
technical standpoint what does it take
to actually make these products so the
sort of landscape of alternatives
there's the plant based product so
that's fairly straightforward right you
grow a crop in the field you harvest the
edible portion of that and then usually
you're isolating or refining or
enriching for the protein fraction of
that and then those go into plant-based
meat products like you know companies
like beyond meat or impossible foods
those are all plant-based protein
sources they're using and what type of
plant-based protein is that yeah a good
question so most of the plant-based
meat products on the market are using
either soy protein or wheat protein in
the last few years people has become
really really popular some like
impossible foods they use potato protein
so a lot of companies are looking to
diversify the source of protein that
they're using because right now it's
been a pretty narrow window yeah
compared to all the possible plant
proteins out there mung bean yeah became
yeah that's exciting it's a whole new
world we have just scratched the surface
in terms of which proteins we're using
and quick question is soy-based protein
there's some
skepticism around that but now there's P
base and mungbean and all these other a
potato base plant protein but it is what
we're doing what is the soy dilemma
thing that's going on yeah so I think I
think there's a lot of misunderstanding
around soy I mean soy does have
potentially an allergenicity issue it is
one of like the the nine most common
allergens so that that is of concern to
consumers I think some of the other you
know previously there were concerns
around you know phytoestrogens in soy
and things like that largely those
concerns really have not been supported
by the data but it's more of a again
it's about giving the consumer what they
want so if consumers say we want a soy
free product or wheat free product or
whatever you know I think companies take
that to heart and that's part of what's
driving this this desire to kind of
explore other sources cool thank you for
that yeah and then we can look at other
basically cell culture based platforms
to produce proteins so all the way on
the right here we've got an animal cell
culture so that's cell based meat
cultured meat clean meat there's a very
active kind of discussion in the field
around what do we call this product but
that's basically growing animal cells
which is obviously what's in meat muscle
cells fat cells etc and and just growing
them directly rather than growing the
whole animal that comes from a stem cell
sample from the that's right origin
source yep yep so at some point you have
to go to an animal either to an adult
animal or you can go to an embryo even
and get that starting material and then
your proliferating it basically in
culture also after that first step here
you're done with the animal and and off
you go but then you can culture other
types of cells too so non animal cell
culture has actually been used in the
food industry for a long time which I
think this is like mycelium right
yeah that's one of the things you could
grow is fungal cells in culture so
there's a company called corn qu ORN
that's been making basically meat all
turn it is out of fungal protein or they
call it mycoprotein
for a really long time and they are also
innovating in this space and you know
developing new types of products and so
forth but you can also use non animal
cell culture to produce specific
proteins that have what's called really
high functionality in food applications
so a lot of food processing enzymes that
have been used again for decades and
decades in the food system are made
through what's called recombinant
protein production where you have you
know say a yeast cell is your host
organism but within that yeast cell you
are you can stick the gene for either an
animal protein or maybe a protein that
is found in the plant kingdom or
somewhere else but you simply want to
make it at really large scale so this is
how we for decades now have been making
chymosin which is the kind of
coagulating enzyme from rennet for
making cheese we used to get it from
scraping calf stomachs but now we simply
produce that enzyme through a
recombinant protein platform so
companies today are taking basically
insulin became huge from very early yeah
so it's very very prevalent in the
pharma industry and therapeutics so
companies today are kind of taking that
paradigm saying you know what other
highly functional animal proteins might
we want to produce in a platform like
this and then combine those with other
plant-based ingredients to get closer to
that consumer experience of the animal
product so for example again going back
to impossible foods they make their
hemoglobin protein it's it's a gene from
soy called like hemoglobin but that
holds the the heme which contributes to
the color of their products and also the
taste of their product issues as well as
iron content so a nutritional claim
there as well yeah and they produce that
through a recombinant platform like this
and that was one of the three main ones
you said taste price
convenient wait can you find it yeah and
then there's companies like Clara foods
is making proteins that are found in egg
white through a platform similar to this
it's got to be indistinguishable and
taste more potentially better it's
actually better yeah so that's what
excites me is once you've kind of
divorced your method of production from
the animal itself you're no longer
restricted to this weird sort of
historical happenstance like we didn't
we didn't go around and canvass the
entire animal kingdom to find that like
cows have the best-tasting milk right
they just happen to like live near us
while we were domesticating animals and
they were relatively amenable to
domestication right but what if the
best-tasting milk or the most nutritious
milk or meat or any other we could make
comes from those yeah from some animal
that like lives nowhere near where
humans live or is really hard to
cultivate the best-tasting milk comes
from Ron right Ron that's done ok let's
let's keep let's keep rolling yeah ok
so let's talk about plant-based meat in
a little more detail because this is one
of the areas where there's actually a
lot of technological innovation that
could happen I think people people like
look at a veggie burger and they say
okay we've had veggie burgers for
decades like how much better could they
get right when really there's been so
little kind of concerted research in the
area of trying to make these products
better that that I think we can get a
really long way so just to kind of set
the stage for what we're doing with
plant-based meat so you're taking a
plant protein and you're trying to make
it taste and behave and structure itself
like an animal protein and these these
proteins tend to be fairly different
from kind of biochemical perspectives
like a potato protein like a beef
protein that's sure yeah yeah so it's
still challenge challenge because the
issue is this you've got these plant
storage proteins
what most of the protein in plants tends
to be it's like say it's stored in the
bean or the seed or whatever it's there
to store those amino acids for that seed
to then ultimately germinate and become
a plant right so they're these storage
proteins they tend to be pretty globular
like they're not really you know
interacting too much within the cell
they're just storing whereas the the
proteins in say meat are these really
functional fibril are kind of you know
muscle fibers basically right so it's a
pretty different structure and that's
why the texture of these products is one
of the trickiest things to to get right
and then of course there's there's the
flavor and all of that yeah so our way
of kind of looking at the technology
challenges is to build out a mind map of
all the various ways in which you all of
the the different basic technological
aspects of this that you need to come to
fruition to make a really good product
so you know starting from the source
material itself should we be using
something like soy or could we find
plant protein sources that just
inherently perform much better in this
type of application that you know don't
taste as be me or that um or that form
these types of structures more easily so
there's a whole host of work to be done
on kind of optimizing those protein
sources from what you just described
this is a big huge challenge and also
there's so much to parse in the food a
possibility arena to see what can work
best exactly yeah that's a lot of mind
mapping to do yeah yeah knowledge
graphing yeah it's exciting but it's
exciting because for all of these there
are so many technologies kind of
enabling technologies that have been
developed in other fields or similar
fields that just haven't yet been
applied to this particular problem
you know take for example advances in
high-throughput breeding for crops so
you can now you know look at all of
these genomic data
we have and develop really sophisticated
breathing algorithms to get a crop that
grows really well in say saline soil
conditions for example you can use that
exact same paradigm but have your
outcome not be growth in a certain type
of soil but performance as a raw
material for plant based meat right so
once you've got your your raw material
then you can enrich for that protein and
then functionalize that protein so you
can use chemical methods you can use
enzymes so biological methods you can
use mechanical methods to help get this
kind of structure and function to make
these products feel and taste like meat
products so as a bit more concrete
example a lot of plant-based meat
companies use a process called extrusion
so you dump this plant protein into this
big expensive heavy piece of equipment
that mixes it with water and basically
uses two steel screws that turn kind of
against each other to melt those
proteins and then align them into fibers
like me yeah so there you're using
basically mechanical force yeah that
kind of structure there's easier ways we
hypothesize do this I think there are so
yeah extrusion is a really old
technology it's been used in a lot of
different sectors everything from you
know plastics to the food industry and
so I think there's a lot of room to look
for better methods that are less
resource intent and less
energy-intensive for example and just
kind of yeah less harsh on the proteins
how do we get the plant-based proteins
to taste and be indistinguishable from
yeah so that's kind of the the last
sector here is the formulation and so
what other kind of flavoring ingredients
are you
flavoring
I mean it's across the board so there
are a lot of you know two ingredients
that contribute to like an umami or
savory flavor for example again to come
back to and how impossible they're using
this heme protein to provide flavor in
some cases you are trying to mask some
of the undesirable flavors from plant
proteins so often plant proteins have
this kind of beanie or bitter flavor so
are their ingredients you can add that
kind of neutralize those and allow some
of the other flavorings to to really
show their true colors thank you Ron
now this this one this is really
important for me because I think that
this speaks volumes to the way that we
are going to be growing the growing meat
in big bio reactors plan a plant-based
and cell base especially yeah like this
cell proliferation for me is is all
about like scale like I'm trying to get
this huge scale as quickly as possible
effectively as possible to get it into
as many grocery stores and yeah yeah
yeah so let's talk about the cell based
product so again clean me cell based
cultured me to call it whatever you wish
yes but plant proteins wouldn't go
through a bioreactor no it's but you
might have some ingredients that are
produced through a cell culture platform
okay but yeah here here we're talking
particularly about the cell based meat
so what you get basically at the end of
this process is meat it is muscle cells
fat cells etcetera from an animal so the
process is basically this you have to
start with a sample of cells from the
animal that you're working with it can
come from an adult animal from something
like a biopsy it can come from an embryo
of that animal so you can start with
several different types of cells and
there's you know kind of downstream
considerations in your process depending
where you first isolate those cells from
but once you have
them then they go into what's called a
seed train so you start from small
number of cells you have to kind of
stage that up you know step by step and
then you can get to sort of large-scale
cell proliferation
so again cells have this beautiful
biological property that one cell
becomes two two become four that arises
to you really really powerful to do this
at large scale if you've got you know
was like ten steps becomes like a
billion or something
yeah that's fast so yeah so the more you
can operate these types of processes you
know continuously and at really large
volume you know if you've got a reactor
that's that's producing the equivalent
of ten thousand pounds of meat in a day
the next day you'll have another ten
thousand pounds the next day you'll have
another ten thousand again it's this
exponential growth yeah Wow so that is
really powerful and then once you've got
this huge number of cells which you know
cells that that proliferate and divide
like that are not cells like mature
muscle cells they're at and of an
earlier stage in their developmental
lineage so at some point once you've got
all your millions and billions and
trillions of cells then you have to go
into kind of Phase two of the process
scaffolding yeah so where you get them
to differentiate and mature into those
desired final cell types so in this
process perfusionist word so yeah so
that's just kind of getting the
nutrients through these cells that are
seated on this kind of 3d spongy
scaffold yeah
that's helping to kind of guide them as
they differentiate into the final cell
types that we want so this is a yeah
this process as a whole is is still
relatively early stage we're still you
know startups working at kind of edge
scale and optimizing the cells they're
working with optimizing the nutrient
media that they're feeding those
but there's there's kind of a lot of
options for what this might ultimately
look like at production scale and
there's a lot of really fundamental yeah
engineering that goes into this I'm so
excited for that design and engineering
to take off because then there's all the
different ways that people will start
exploring this but then there's the FDA
USDA like cracking down on like making
sure that its proper yeah all of these
conversations are and should be
happening in parallel because you know
regulatory considerations or food safety
considerations should be part and parcel
of the process design right and and even
you know thinking about what type of
attributes do you want for your cell
line is determined by what you think
this process will ultimately look like
at industrial scale so this field is is
fascinating because it's really
important for different aspects of this
research and development to not get
siloed right there needs to be a really
robust conversation and communication
some open sourcing exactly that would be
great we've been sourcing to the to the
cell agriculture and biotech and
bioreactors that'd be great one of the
endeavors that we're currently trying to
coordinate is basically a clean meat
Research Center so that you could have
you know potential industry partners or
startup companies or academics come and
kind of iterate on a process have you
know an actual safe pilot scale facility
that's modular and you can play around
with different unit operations or you
know produce some sample that you can
then test for nutritional equivalents
and kind of allow all of these other
studies to be done that can really
contribute to this industry yeah so just
to give a sense of how quickly this
industry has grown so at the end of 2016
less than two years ago we're in October
2018 now there were arguably only four
companies in this space and the picture
today is actually even bigger than this
so there's some companies that are so
young they
don't have a logo or they're still in
stealth mode so they haven't announced
themselves to the world and what I find
really exciting is that these span the
entire globe there's companies on here
in the US obviously in Canada in Israel
in Japan and Singapore China so we're
seeing a lot of innovation and they're
they're all taking a somewhat different
approach based on you know who the
founders are and what their strengths
are that they're bringing to the table
yeah it's very exciting I love it and
this is in by 2020 it's just gonna be
just gonna be exploding yeah but I think
it's also really exciting is how many
other industries are now getting
involved in this so it's no longer just
a bunch of little startups kind of
generating iterating around this center
of this this again mind map here for the
clean meat industry it's you know
companies that have deep deep expertise
for example in developing cell culture
media that nutrient feed who are now
saying look this is a business
opportunity if and if we as a company
don't get involved we're missing out on
a huge growth opportunity so I think
that will only accelerate the rate of
progress in this field same with the
billions of dollars pouring in yeah and
the different optimizations in the
process yeah same with the bio reactors
and kind of this process design in the
facility we've now got you know
long-standing engineering firms that
have done you know processing facilities
for the petrochemicals industry for
decades and decades they're now looking
at this saying how can we bring our
expertise that's cool it's very cool
yeah yeah yeah who would have thought
that that would be happening that's
great so you'll maybe get a phone call
from these different industries saying
that we can bring our process down and
help yeah and some of them are the same
companies that I was mowing two years
ago and they were saying oh that's cute
like this sounds like a really sci-fi
endeavor and kind of laughed it off and
now they see how quickly things have
happened
in the last couple years they're calling
back and saying actually come work
shopping with us we want to be involved
yeah yep
so this is one of my favorite points to
make and it's a great closing point for
for anyone who's listening right now
who's kind of thinking you know should I
get involved is this the right time you
know what's the the chance that my
little Rd project could actually
contribute in a meaningful way again I'm
very like outcomes driven right so these
spheres are looking at the amount of
global R&D investment that's gone into
each of these different renewable energy
technologies in a single year so this
happens just be from 2011 found these
numbers so you can see billions in some
cases tens or even over a hundred
billion into a single type of renewable
energy and and obviously we've seen
tremendous growth in that sector but
it's taken many many years of these
types of R&D investments by contrast you
know we've seen all of the traction in
the meet alternative space both on the
plant-based side of things plus this
ridiculous growth in the clean meat
industry that has been happening on a
total shoestring budget so combined
across all years we estimate there's
maybe been one or maybe two billion
dollars of rnd investment in jellal meat
alternatives plant-based and cleanly
combined so like this is your you know
this is like the child is just born a
couple days ago basically that's like
you know there's a long wait until the
child's a teenager's let alone and
adults so get in early give in early but
also like look how much progress has
been made on just a little bit of
resource yeah I think it's you know like
this is not gonna be as tough of a nut
to crack as solar energy I really don't
think I really think that this is what
subtractive all solvable you know it
needs smart people and it needs
resources no doubt like nothing here is
trivial but I think this is in terms of
like bang for your buck whether that's
you know kind of in your career or
literal like a research dollar to
outcome
to outcome to took huge sustainable
impact the world is exactly yeah that's
this is a great place to be for that
totally that's why I see so many venture
capitalists and that are really excited
about this space because they care more
about that sustainable impact this is a
way that they can actually see a return
as well in many ways there's there's a
term that gets used a lot in this
industry especially among investors
called double bottom line so making a
lot of money but also doing a lot of
good good for the world so what are
those kind of social impact metrics that
come along with your investment dollars
entries I love that actually I really
love that a lot because there's there's
a lot of pressure going on by the
capitalist system to be like oh you're
social good for investing it doesn't
make any money and then the capitalist
side of things is like well we're gonna
invest into whatever no matter what even
if it's not sustainable
so actually I'm a huge fan of that
double bottom line conversation that's
that's it that's that's a good one it's
like a very beautiful alignment of
everyone's incentives yes yes what do
you foresee as one of the most exciting
parts of the future of meat I think so
I'm really excited by the fact that all
of these various industries are showing
up at the table including you know the
meat industry like we talked about
they've been making investments they've
been developing their own product lines
etc I find that really exciting because
that means that we're not gonna have to
to fight the industry that's getting
disrupted here they actually want to be
part of this disruption really really
cool yeah they're not trying to like
start fires in the field they're trying
to help poor resources yeah that's good
yeah absolutely and then kind of within
the landscape of meat alternatives one
area that I think is particularly urgent
and particularly necessary but maybe
gets talked about less is seafood and I
think that we are starting to see more
traction in that area but there's a ton
left to do so this is one of our most
recent white papers that kind of maps
out where we think a lot of these
opportunities are what makes the sea
sector unique from what we call
terrestrial meat and and you know how
that can be leveraged by folks who want
to innovate in this space and this is
one of my favorites right here this this
round in the top right corner the the
aquaculture production over time has
just been increasing to the point where
it's asked much now in 2030 projected to
be as capture production rate so we're
no longer going to be pulling from the
ecosystems of fish but rather making but
I think so here I think aquaculture is
maybe a short-sighted solution I think
there's a lot of potential to make
plant-based seafood exactly or you know
cell based seafood but that's what
finless is doing exactly the cell based
yeah
so rather than even growing in the
aquaculture ecosystems it's all about so
I like to think about it like this so
right now we are at a time in
civilization where 50% of our seafood is
wild caught basically hunted and 50% is
farmed through domestic fish right
imagine that point in history for
land-based meat where we were still
hunting 50% of our meat and the other
50% we were affirming that was thousands
of years ago right and and this you know
our kind of reliance on this very
intensified industrialized animal
agriculture with all of these
externalize harms maybe we would see
that with the aquaculture industry too
so we really have an opportunity here to
be ahead of that curve what if we were
developing you know cell based meat
substitutes or alternatives 3000 years
ago when we were at that kind of tipping
point where would we be now we could
have kind of completely saved ourselves
basically from from all of the harms of
that industry you know why I love you
that you pulled an incredible reference
from history from evolution and how we
made a transition to more animals that
we were farming
other than wildly hunting and now same
thing with oceans we're not going to be
yeah pulling from massive ecosystems of
fish it looks ridiculous those videos
where they're pulling a football field
of fish onto a boat yeah that looks
ridiculous
yeah it's absurd and it's time to
transition away from that yeah yeah I'm
Wow Wow great so Liz this has been such
a amazing conversation I'm just so
blessed to have had you on the show
teaching us about the future of meat and
all of it in this much nuanced as we can
in the short time we have together we
typically ask a couple questions out of
the show but I just want to ask you Mike
one of my favorite ones which is what he
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world my answer to this might sound a
little lame because I'm a biologist but
I think a cell honestly it's like this
beautiful chaotic universe within itself
that that can be you know persuaded to
behave in a different way but but
without any instruction just kind of
knows how to operate it's this
autonomous machine that I think is
really beautiful
yes yes we need to do a whole show on
just the intricacies of a cell and like
how gorgeous and beautiful that is
because I have totally agree with you
but I know 0.0001% I want to know more
and teach more about that Liz Wow
thank you so much for coming onto the
show thank you super fun Oh glad you had
a good time I know that we are
progressing towards a beautiful
sustainable future thanks to
organizations like good food Institute
people like you well we need more folks
in this field so if this at all excites
you find opportunities here yeah that
little tiny 1 2 billion dollar bubble is
going to be like hundreds of billions of
dollars and exciting and there's double
bottom lines there's all this cool stuff
the explore stop slaughtering animals
and yeah and let's let's get our [ __ ]
together civilization much love everyone
thank you so much for tuning in
give us a comment below let us know your
thoughts about the industry about the
space about what we discuss on the show
let's build the community together also
like we were to saying go create go
build go manifest your destiny into the
world and thank you Liz thank you good
food Institute go check out the link in
the bio thank you Ron our producer
director and much love everyone we'll
talk to you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you